hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
today i have a review for you of this
uh audioquest uh dragonfly
uh cobalt i guess cobalt blue
this comes in three different versions
uh standard one which i think is gray
then or black i forget then there's a
red one and then this is the cobalt one
and the price incrementally goes up
as you get to this one this is uh 300
for this uh little thing
so uh quite expensive it doesn't look or
feel any different than the
cheaper ones maybe it feels a little bit
more uh glossy but
at any rate it's not something you're
gonna look at every day
on this thing so for 300 it better be a
darn good
dongle um because you can get really
nice ones now for
75 to 100
if you're not familiar with this
category of device on one side there's a
usb connection and on the other side
there's a headphone jack
internally there's a dac in there
digital to analog converter
and a headphone amplifier two combined
are designed to produce better
performance than you can get out of your
headphone jack out of your laptop
or if you have a phone that still has a
headphone jack or if it doesn't then
this is your
only solution something like this is the
only solution to get
audio out so compared to the
analog output of your desktop we expect
these things to have a lot more output
as far as just sheer power of driving
headphones otherwise there's no point in
having these
whether they provide additional fidelity
that's a secondary thing to
have an adequate power and we'll be
measuring that
on this thing so this is what it looks
like let's get into the review that i
post last night
um click in my window here
so i do this test in
two phases in that at first i treat all
of these as if they're
just a standalone deck meaning i don't
try to
load the output with a headphone style
load
so it's the least stressful situation
which is what a
dac would see when he's driving a
preamplifier as opposed to a headphone
and for that i try to adjust the output
to 2 volts if i can
and see what the performance is so again
it's the best case performance
with autoquest cobalt when i
ran my dashboard test i the signal is
always 0dbfs which means it's at maximum
digital value at peak to peak at the
sine wave
when i did that performance was
horrendous uh
this sign add which indicates noise and
distortion
just sank all the way down to 25 or 30.
these distortion bars were way to heck
up here
and a clear sign that the device wasn't
designed to be driven at full amplitude
a lot of music these days is mixed near
zero because of these loudness wars
so you don't want it uh dac to uh
clip or overload in in in that case
excuse me um so i knocked it down one db
and that was enough to get rid of the
severe clipping and
uh that gave me the two volt nominal
which is what a
dag should produce uh and uh performance
still pretty dismal
uh cyanide again it says is a measure of
all these harmonics added together and
the noise floor of the dag combined
and uh we're getting somewhere between
74 and 78 depending on what channel you
look at
you average them up you get about i
don't know 75
or so 76 and that places the uh
um audioquest cobalt um
second worst donkel i've ever tested
there's i don't know 25 30 of them in
here if not more
and anything bucket red means it's just
incompetent
essentially at any price much less of
300
ideally you get a device that's in the
green and blue is where you want it to
be
not weigh the heck down here so as a
pure dac this is
quite disappointing um what's
interesting is that this uses a
pretty competent uh digital to analog
converter from ess
that in desktop situation it can
actually be way above
even these lines over here so
quite surprising it took a really good
engine and then
screwed up its output to to be this bad
now sometimes the performance is better
at lower voltages
or lower output levels so let's test for
that and
uh as you can see performance
just keeps getting worse the more you
ask this device to produce
output usually the curve sort of starts
low because of the noise level that's
dominant
and then it goes up and then it comes
back down not here basically
the more output you have the worse the
up the performance gets
and distortion increases and then it
hits a point where it just clips
and performs drops like a rock and
that's all there is um as a sign that
there's a good engine in there
of that dac is that when we just measure
noise not distortion just measure noise
is extremely good it's not the best but
it's way up there this is producing
basically 20 bits of
dynamic range so very quiet internals in
there
it's really the distortion that's the
problems all these tile spikes in here
the noise floors
is pretty good going back to distortion
uh people complain often that you know
you're just running one sine wave that's
music not one sine wave so i have a test
where i run 32 sine waves
at all different frequencies from 20
hertz all the way up to 20 kilohertz
and an ideal output on this would be
that the bottoms will be way down here
and
there won't be any of this busyness or
grass as we call it
here we're getting really bad output but
the distortions
are generated are covering all the way
up to -80 db
if we divide that by six we get about 13
bits of distortion free range so if you
express this clean area you only have 13
bits so
i don't know 40 years after cd format
was started at
16 bits this device can produce 16 bits
i think
you know anything about 13 bits it's
just pure distortion and
and junk i don't know who can argue that
this is euphonic or sounds good
it's just garbage that's just gonna hide
detail in your music
excuse me um i notice in the description
they talked about it has a slow filter
and so i figured i go ahead and measure
the filter response
and the way i do that is that i feed
this the
white noise and white nose has all
frequencies in it so this will go on
infinity every dac needs a filter and
this one has a filter but this filter is
very slow
an ideal filter for this sample rate
would truncate everything at this blue
line
that doesn't alway most of the time that
doesn't happen most stacks have
what i call lazy roll out but
the laziness is not as lazy as this and
also they don't uh
bring down the levels of audio audible
band too much
there's about five or six db droop over
here at 20 kilohertz
fortunately most of us don't hear that
but if we did hear it
you know you're basically losing some of
your highs in there so
not good um this is done because of this
notion that normal dac filters are
sharper and are flat in the audible band
ring meaning that they oscillate and
then they have a spike and then they
oscillate
that only happens with artificial test
signal and impulse doesn't happen with
music
but what the heck we'll go ahead and run
a square wave test
and indeed we see that there is uh only
pulse ringing
and so the signal comes and we see the
ringing
after it we don't see any ringing before
it so it's doing what he says it's doing
even though audibility of this thing is
quite suspect this kind of filter
but uh despite the fact that i'm running
this at -2 db
uh full scales not even one we see the
tops of these things i don't know if you
can see they're flat they should be
little points like this
not flattened when they're flattened
meaning that
the dac is internally digitally clipping
and when it clips it generates
distortion so
this is not good it's an overflow
digital systems cannot handle overflow
uh they they're great till you get to
zero and then they can't go above zero
so there's a signal processing error
here
uh it's rather common uh it happens
so uh but still not forgivable
you know we don't want clipping in the
name of the code a dac
filter that we can't even quantify what
it does for us it uh
gets rid of some of our frequency
response up here and then it gets
and it then clips in in time domain so
not good
but this shackle of high personality
continues when i
test for accuracy of of the output
in a linearity test is exceptionally
good it's almost textbook perfect all
the way up to 20 bits again 120
minus 120 db so there's great
performance there it's great performance
in a jitter test yes there's some
unwanted spikes here you should only see
this one spike in the middle
that's our test signal everything else
should be you know it shouldn't be there
we've seen these little ticks in here
and that's common especially in this
class device
but the levels are all below minus 130
db and lower so absolutely inaudible
um on this thing so definitely not a
concern so
performance goes from being you know
really terrible to
really good now a lot of these things
where i've shown you it's not clear that
you know average person even hears this
high uh
distortion uh here distortions you need
training
and and right content to hear it and
uh at this level i think most
audiophiles wouldn't hear
these artifacts even though you know
ideally you want to get a piece of
hardware that doesn't have those
problems
so but what you do here is power as i
mentioned at the start of this review
in that if you run out of power either
the thing doesn't get loud enough to
drive your headphone or
it will get severely distorted in this
case when i'm running a 300
ohm load which simulates something like
a sennheiser hd 650 or hd6xx series
headphones are quite popular for these
we measure we keep increasing the input
relative and measure what comes out as
far as output
watts in here and how much distortion we
get
once again we see this is a very high
distortion device in that
you know before you even get to 0.1
milliwatts this is 0.1
we're already having distortion taken
over and increasing with level
and uh then it gets to a point of about
12 milliwatt
and then it jumps up uh unclips
so you know this is your usable ranges
in here so if i take that 12 milliwatt
and i plot it with all the other dongles
like this that i've tested
it lands in here uh your phone it like
is way down here like this htc i think
it's the htc
phone i don't know if i can see my oh
here we go by
i think this is my samsung phone i'm not
sure but if you have a regular phone
with without a dongle uh other than some
lg phones
uh you're way down here so there's
plenty more power
than your uh typical uh uh either phone
or if you buy
little dongles like the apple dongle
here's
three and a half milliwatts this thing
puts out 12 milliwatts so it's four
times
more powerful than the apple dongle
which is actually a good dongle on the
google and others you could try to
look at the review online so this is
actually not bad
uh i'd like to see 14 15 16 which is
what this
is or in case of higher end ones that
have balance
outputs like this uh hidey's s9
in here you can see that it puts out as
much as 52 milliwatts which is
more than four times the power so if you
have power hungry
high impedance headphones you may have
trouble with this
we then go to the other extreme because
headphones come in all kinds of
impedances
um that was a test of a high impedance
we want to test low impedance because
low impedance stresses current delivery
and a headphone app may be good at
voltage and not current or vice versa
ideally
it would be good at both so here we see
a similar picture where distortion rises
early again
and this time though we don't have a lot
of power it's 26 milliwatts and if we
plot that against
all the other dongles and the phones
that i've tested night lands
way down here um it should really be
in this category uh over here so this
tells me that
if you have a high impedance headphone
this dongle probably do okay
but if you have a low impedance
headphone
that lands in this 25 30 ohm range
you're not gonna have a lot of power
and depending on the efficiency of that
headphone you may have clipping issues
or volume issues
indeed that's what happened so i always
test with two headphones one at high
impedance one at low impedance for that
same reason
with sennheiser hd 650 i thought this
sounded excellent
um plenty of volume plenty of punch
plenty of dynamics detail what
distortion was there
i couldn't hear it by just listening
with just one sample
maybe if i did an a b test between this
and another
lower distortion one i could hear a
difference but you know for
practice as a matter of practice uh it's
uh it's fine uh it's with the high
impedance then a second test
i do is that i have this ether cx from
drop
it's only 25 ohm impedance
i tested with that and at very low
volume
it sounded fine but the moment i got to
medium volume
it was already distorted and by the time
i got it to max volume
it was severely distorted not a subtle
thing maybe not just a little bit
bright or anything it was just
completely gone
it was basically operating in the
clipping region over here
uh on this thing where distortion just
goes through the roof
it's almost as strong as the signal
itself and there's no mistaking there
you you know if you listen to any
headphone in this range
you're already in trouble down here yeah
this this may be hard to hear
but clearly the you know i needed more
power than 26 milliwatts to drive this
excuse me um ether cx headphone and
that's unfortunate and whereas if i test
with the exact same two headphones ether
cx with any of the ones in here
sound is beautiful um you can get the
recently
reviewed thx onyx
one or uh e1da
or tempo tech there's just a ton of
choices in here
and they're all much cheaper than this
and they just have
tremendous performance so
what's going on in here basically looks
like
there's some subsystem is good in here
but basically the headphone amplifier is
junk
um it doesn't have enough power uh
and it generates a lot of distortion and
audioquest is getting unlucky in some
extent so they're sitting on their
laurels with this design they're one of
the early pioneers
in this area made this category quite
popular
but some eight or ten years gone by and
the race has moved on and people are now
producing
these little dongles like this that by
the way um
come with us pcs you just have a little
cable connected to your phone connecting
this to your phone
is pretty onerous because you need a big
adapter that then dangles from your
phone and
having more weight is not a good thing
and even if you plug this into a laptop
if you walk away with your headphone
you can break the expensive usb
jack in your uh laptop these new ones
where they have
you know either a small cable attached
or or at least usbc
are much nicer and some of them like
this one actually have
volume up and down which is very very
good rather than trying to reach into
the device reach into the phone and try
to change the volume
on this thing so where does it net out
terrible i mean they could have measured
all these things found these problems
and fix
them come with a better implementation i
don't know if they didn't measure they
didn't understand
they didn't compare or what it is but i
personally wouldn't buy this at any
price
you know 50 i can get a far better
device than this thing
and i just see no reason for this to
exist
whatsoever yes at high impedance it will
sound fine with high impedance
headphones
and i'm sure all those uh reviewers
online that gush over it
are probably just using either very easy
to drive headphone
or one that's high impedance and that
defeats the purpose of
spending three hundred dollars because
you won't spend three hundred dollars so
that whatever happened you buy in the
future
you don't have to buy this again this is
not a ten dollar item you throw away get
another one
um when you buy a new headphone um so
uh and at a day rate there's nothing
that i can justify
should cost 300 i think 150 is the limit
of what you want to pay
thx onyx is 200 so a little bit of a
stretch there but otherwise
there's just no reason to pay 300 for
anything it's not
jewelry it doesn't it's not something
you're going to show off to people
it literally shouldn't exist but exists
and he sells
strongly i think there were 2 000
reviews on amazon alone
and all those people are i guess they
don't know about us
and don't know about the reviews i do
and you know charts like this where
so many better products exist in this
one and tend to go spend the money
on this so it's a classic case of
writing a brand
and reputation rather than a proper
design
the other versions of audioquest
dragonfly don't do well either by the
way the red one is not competitive and
the plain one is not either although
they're at least
more in the ballpark than this one is
they don't clip as easily as this
and at least you don't pay as much for
them so really no reason to buy this
anybody who gushes over it you know i
suggest not watching their channel read
their reviews again because
i tell you you throw away all the
measurements and just look at the
just listen to it you hook up a proper
headphone to it and it's distorting uh
it's just you know open and shut case
uh on this thing got 300 dollars so
all rights hopefully uh you got
something out of this review
uh see you in the future one bye bye